- [Interviewer] What do they call you,
Jack fella or Black Heff?
- Black Heff man, the
Black Heff, man, the flesh
same nigga, different bank roll.
You want to interview both of them
it's going to cost you twice as much.
Black Heff man, and then Hollywood.
Appreciate the time, you bringing me out
you know what I'm talking about?
Hear the true story.
Everybody want to know.
People don't know.
- [Interviewer] Come on in.
- Yeah, he doing, like,
he just a cool nigga.
He the black Heff man, he got the--
the black Heff is a different Negro, man.
That's what I'm trying to tell you.
He's something, he
something way unique man.
I got, man, I got little kids
want to be the black Heff.
Do you believe that?
- [Interviewer] Your way.
- My biggest peer pressure is the church.
- [Interviewer] Is that right?
- The chairman, as I call him, the Bishop,
he's my biggest peer pressure.
He's 70 years old, almost.
Peer pressure supposed to be around,
amongst the age of your peers.
He's my biggest peer
pressure, so long story short,
I don't even, I hadn't even smoked
when I came out here.
I'd been quit smoking.
But getting with the church, this Cali.
He smoke everywhere he
go, everywhere we go.
It don't matter if before,
when they wasn't even
legal in other States.
Once he came Cali, he'd go to other states
and be smoking in the club right in there.
And the people have to throw us out.
And he'd be like,
"okay, come on, let's go,
It ain't nothing." Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How
are you and the Bishop?
- Oh, the church is, my God,
We'd been together for--been together
since I'm at least around
around 2000, 2000, 2001.
- [Interviewer] So you're, you're from
Flint, Michigan, originally.
- Born and raised in Flint.
- [Interviewer] And when
did you get started,
started with pimping?
- Well, I once got
introduced to the game around
maybe was it '99? About 2000,
almost 2000.
So about '99, 2000.
- How'd you get introduced to that?
- I was on a search to find, just to find
what was available out
there in the world to me.
I knew it was something
more than was in Flint.
You know, just the dope
dealing and the, you know,
just the hustling, basically, back then.
You know mainly crack, weed,
you know, little things,
you know, that became bigger.
But at the time I just knew it
was something else out there
in the world, a better opportunity.
So I went out there looking for it.
And once I got to Memphis,
I actually had to stay there on accident.
But when I stayed there on the accident
a little longer than I really expected
when I first went there,
I acquired the information
from the guy that--a guy that was actually
in the business and knew, you know,
had a different route than
I had previously seen.
I had never seen this route.
I thought he--I always
seen him, like he had money
but I never knew what he really did.
I thought he was selling drugs,
like every other person
that ever come out of Flint.
So, but long story short,
he had a whole different thing set up.
And he was dealing with, you
know, with the strip clubs.
And he was having a life
of a guy that was kingpin.
And so to me, from the outside, looking in
or even bigger, actually,
so long story short,
he acquired--I acquired
the information through him
to find out how to do what he was doing.
And as he was telling me,
I wasn't taking it serious
but once I,
oh, this what happened.
True story.
My man had, he had
been giving me the information
about the business for awhile.
And I was in town maybe about
maybe a week and a half,
two weeks after I originally
planned on staying
cause I had a good friend of mine
that was there as well beside this guy.
But they both were from Flint.
But this guy was like
I said, living a life
that was unbelievable so,
once he had been telling
me about, you know,
I could get girls and girls
will like me and I can do it.
I just was, you know, procrastinating,
because I really wasn't, you know,
I had my mind and heart on
other things at this time,
you know, I really wasn't
passionate about it
but I just seen what
he was having from it,
and that was, you know,
something to admire alone.
So once I, once he, we
got together one day
and I was trying to buy some weed
and I didn't have the
money on me at the time
to buy the ounce I wanted.
So I was telling him,
let me borrow some money.
But I had money put up,
you know, somewhere.
But the people where my money was at
happened to be out of town.
And he knew that, so it was no problem,
but I told him, I said, "man,
let me borrow some money,"
"you know, I need about
200 to buy this ounce."
He said, "man," and he
said this one thing.
He said, "that's what I'm
saying about you niggas."
He said, "y'all,"
He said, "now, you know, I done told you"
"how to do the game and what you can do"
"to get money with the girls,"
"and you still wanted
something about you buying,"
He said, "if you would
have been got that girl"
"that says you can you can get down here,
"you would have been made
that money and more money"
"been able to buy as
many ounces as you want."
So when he said the
one word, "you niggas,"
it was like something triggered in me.
Like he thought I was like a different,
you know, like, a weaker.
I don't know what he thought,
but I guess he thought
I was a weaker version
of whatever his version was
when he said, "you niggas."
And that just stuck, you
know, struck a flame in me.
And then I got the girl
down there, you know,
they said she would come
and got her in the club.
His girl took her to the club
and she started making money.
Not as much as his girl was making.
But the money started being made.
And from there, I was
able to see, you know,
what really basically managing the girl,
you know what I'm saying?
In the club, you know what I'm saying?
Could really, the profits you could bring.
And once I seen that, it was on from there
to try to expand the business
and get more people for it to
grow, and to get more money.
So that's what I did.
And that was in Memphis, Tennessee.
- [Interviewer] How'd you grow up?
You had both your parents?
- Yeah. I grew up my parents
but I was just, you know,
they was never married.
- [Interviewer] But you
had Mom and Dad around?
- Yeah. Mom and Daddy. Yeah.
Well, different times, I lived with mom
and I lived with dad, but between the both
I stayed mostly with
either one of them mother.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- It was cool.
I just, you know, it
was, it was, it was hard
but it was love, you know?
So I, like I said, either
way or anything, I went
with my grandmother, my
mother's mother had money.
And her and her husband, you know,
which was my grandfather's
step-grandfather
they worked in General Motors.
I'm from Flint, Michigan,
of course, you know,
it's General Motors everywhere.
It was a lot of that GM money around.
So, but with them, I lived
a fairly spoiled life.
But then when I went to my
father's mother and went
to the hood, you know, it
was like a three bedroom
with like, maybe 10, eight,
and anywhere from eight to
13 people living there at
one time, all the time.
You know, one bathroom,
really a half of one downstairs
work every now and then,
you know, where there's
people in the basement,
laying on the couch downstairs,
and us kids upstairs in the bedroom,
you know, plus grandma's room.
So it was, but like I said, it was hard,
you know, but it was love.
So with the love, it was fun, you know,
you know, they made it, you know,
you didn't know to notice the struggle
and recognize what the, you know,
what it was because it was love.
- [Interviewer] So you got
started in the game at what age?
- Which game? (laughs)
Oh, well, yeah, yeah.
Well, like I said, I call it management,
but yeah, same thing.
At the beginning stages,
when I first found it,
that's what the man that told me,
that's what he was doing.
He had a whole, a whole different formula
that he worked through the dance clubs.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- At that time, I was 25 going on 26.
- [Interviewer] And how
many girls did you have
in your stable with, at the peak?
- Six.
- [Interviewer] Six?
- Yeah. I was living in a half,
a million dollar house on,
I live in a half a million dollar house
on five acres, six bedrooms,
five and a half baths.
Yeah, it was yeah, six.
- [Interviewer] This is where?
- This was in Tennessee.
- [Interviewer] In Tennessee.
- Yeah, in Memphis.
- [Interviewer] Memphis.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you'd
have sex with the girls?
- Yeah, well, it depends
on which one earned that
you know, earned that at the time,
how I work, you know, how
the game went, you know,
you just don't jump off
having sex with a chick.
You know, it, ain't a, you know,
ain't matrimony, it's macaroni, you know,
so you really, when you really doing it,
how I started it, you know,
me, I wanted to give what
I gave through the streets
and hustling to the game
that I had embarked on.
And I didn't want to be
phony and fake, you know,
and be trying to beat, you know,
and so I wanted to know exactly
how the game really went.
And to find out what it, how
it really supposed to go.
So when I found out how it
was supposed to go, I'll be,
I wouldn't be breaking any rules.
Cause I didn't really know how it'd go,
I didn't have nobody teach me the game.
I just heard my man, long story short,
the guy that taught me,
brought me down there,
and gave me the information originally
within 45 to 60 days me
and him had a falling out
and we didn't talk for years, you know?
So it just so happened, I ended up
running into the Bishop
and them through Snoop,
through Northern people that knew Snoop,
and I went to see Snoop and
then the Bishop was there
and the story goes on,
but I didn't have a teacher
or the other information
to really know. I just had some examples;
a uncle that was a pimp,
that was my momma's brother.
They tell me stories about him,
and I used to see him when I was young
but he sold dope and did it.
So I really had no nowhere to
to acquire the actual
information of how the game
is really supposed to go.
Being from Flint, Michigan.
But when I went to Memphis,
it's a town where pimping is everywhere.
You know, pimping is like,
I always tell people,
"pimping in Memphis
like selling insurance,"
"you can go door to
door with it." (laughs)
- [Interviewer] And so the arrangement is,
you keep all the girls' money.
The girl brings you all the money?
- Well, I provide a unique service.
I mean, we talked about then, or now?
- [Interviewer] Either one.
- Well, the whole time, it's,
now, I like, a lot of times,
with the clients that I have
that's with the company I got now,
I don't even have to be there.
You know, I've already trained
people to know how to go.
So they basically manage the money,
do the deposit, they take
care of the deposits,
they do all of the, everything
that got to go with the business.
I don't even have to, you
know, so now I got it.
But back then, when I was, you know,
just finding out about everything,
and didn't know, I initially
started out pimping.
But then once I realized that, you know,
I was just dealing with clubs,
and these clubs are legitimate.
Why shouldn't I be legitimate?
So then I figured out the
best way to be able to
take what I was doing and do it
in a legitimate fashion and
figure out how to do that.
That was paying taxes,
having my bank account,
having my statements, doing
all the things that it took,
you know, doing everything it took,
the report to the IRS and
do everything properly,
so that way my business can last
and I can continue to do it,
even if I don't have a girl,
but I got a legitimate business
when I find the right person to understand
and agree to the contracts
and the terms and agreement that we do,
then bam, it's, everything can fail.
I can continue to grow
and move, but if not?
- [Interviewer] And avoid prison time.
- Oh, definitely to avoid prison time.
Yeah, definitely. To what, like I said,
I'm from Flint though.
So I came from hustling in
the streets, so it made me...
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever gone to prison?
- No, never.
- No, I've been to county jail,
but, you know, I never,
no, but all, everybody
I know went to prison
or died on their way to prison.
So, you know, with that being said,
you know, I was always,
that was my thing of
escaping, from leaving Flint,
when I went to Memphis and was moving
I went to Atlanta to ended up in Memphis
but I was trying to find, like I said,
I'm originally from the streets, hustling,
into the music.
You know, I took my own money
and first took myself to the
studio from selling crack,
I took myself to the studio and paid
for my own studio time and my own beats.
So I was like maybe 16, then.
15 going on 16 year, like
at the end of the year.
Like end of 15, going on 16 years.
- [Interviewer] drugs have
been a part of your life?
In the past?
- Oh, just hustling, that's all I,
you know, that's only way.
I mean, I had, if I left,
I lived in, I, like I said
my family normally at
my grandmother house,
the one on my father's side,
it was always no less
than eight to 13 people
in the one in the, you know,
three bedrooms, you know?
So I mean, there's people
around doing everything
it's uncles and aunties, they friends.
So I learned about, you know,
seeing people doing and using drugs and,
and how to make money off of drugs.
And that it was, you know,
a profitable thing when I was very young.
You know, and I kind of
like really learned it
in my own household.
From my auntie keeping my dope when I went
to school, and having her
friends come by the whole time,
I think that she was buying it,
smoking it, just with her check,
but I didn't know no better.
She just said she had customers,
she helped me move it.
- [Interviewer] And the
girls that worked for you,
they were using, or not?
- Oh no, no.
I never had girls using.
If I had a girl to use, I always could be,
like, once again, I came from the streets
and I know, I know a dope fiend
to make a dope fiend move.
So I never wanted to take the chance
of dealing with girls that was on drugs
because I always knew that if I,
if I make a mistake, then I stand for it.
But if somebody else make a mistake,
and I brought them to stand with me,
then the mistake is still on me.
So I had to find out a way
to make what I did mistake
proof, so to speak.
So, no, I never dealt with
any girls that was on drugs.
And if they were on drugs,
it wasn't condoned by me at all.
Funny story, when I was in Memphis,
when I was pimping, I got
three, I had three girls,
my three main chicks, and I went
and bought three drug tests,
cause I found out that you
can get the same, you know,
tests that you get at
the probation office,
at, you know, at Walgreens or whatever.
So I go and buy three of them.
So now I'm threatening the girls
that I'm gonna give them drug tests.
So these, these are girls that have been
with me for a while,
when I was in Memphis.
So when my daddy stayed
with me at this time.
He got out of prison and stayed with me.
So when I got ready to get a girl's,
I gave one of them a drug test
when I gave the one drug test,
cause I told them no drugs, you know?
So when I gave the one that drug test,
she test positive for cocaine and pills,
some kind of pills, you
know what I'm saying?
So, you know, so I had,
you know, had to deal
with that situation and, you
know, address that, whatever.
But once I did it, you know,
I had two more relatives left.
And so my daddy was, my daddy has,
was there to see, you
know, the whole thing.
He kind of a jokester.
So he said, "go on ahead, get the other
to the other tests and
see what that look like."
And guess what I said, "forget them drugs.
Cause I ain't thinking about it.
I don't even want to
see no more," you know,
so, but no, I always,
you know, the whole time,
like I said, because of the drugs,
and from Flint and all that,
growing up with it in my
own house, it was always
my thing was to try to
get far away from it.
When I did leave Flint,
the best way I can.
That's why when I found pimping,
it was such a beautiful
thing because it was a way
for me to totally eliminate
the drugs, you know?
And the only way that I knew to make money
and survive was hustling, you know,
you know, with drugs
that's all I had knew,
you know, selling crack,
so weed and you know, whatever other
thing came up that was profitable.
But anyway, yeah, the game, the game,
I tell people all the time
the game saved me, you
know, game saved me.
The Bishop always say, he say,
he done seen this game,
you know, ruin people.
And he done seen this game,
you know, change people lives
for the better, you know, and
I can truly say that I'm one
of the persons who this
game really changed my life
for the better, you know,
in so many different ways.
So, you know, and I have no
regrets about none of it.
I'm thankful, you know,
for the transition,
from the streets of really
coming from a lot of drugs
and everything negative
and use of, see a fool, use
a fool kind of mentality,
and beat everybody, and get over,
and stealing, taking, lying.
You know, it was just, you know,
for me to go from that to pimping
it wasn't no big deal,
I was already, you know,
just a different kind
of game and another
kind of money, you know,
but once I seen the kind
of money that was legitimately
able to be acquired
with the kind of, with the
legitimacy of using clubs
to be able to get the
money from, all I had to do
was manage the people that
was going into the clubs.
You know what I'm saying,
create my business
create my contracts and then
get a mutual understanding that
was profitable for the both.
And so that's what I was
able to do with some CPAs
and some lawyers and, and you
know, the rest is history.
You got the Black Heff
sitting in front of you.
- [Interviewer] What's your style
of interacting with the girls?
I mean, a lot of the guys
I've talked to have been like
they use intimidation they--
- No, no, my, I tell people all the time
- [Interviewer] Smooth talker?
- Honesty is my best policy.
That's what I learned.
I've learned by being able
to be honest with the girls
tell them what's upfront,
tell them what it is
tell them, you know, what's expected.
You know, all the, you know
all the scenarios possible
before they actually
extract themselves into,
you know, the aspect of doing it.
I give them every, you know,
every good and bad
scenario I possibly can,
so they can make a clear
decision to be able to see
if this something they want
to do or not want to do.
And I'm not tricking
nobody into something.
I'm not forcing somebody to do something.
Like, what I offer is a
unique service that has
already changed women's lives,
them, their kids, you know,
I've had girls that
come down from Michigan
and sign up with the company
and they daughter was three
years old at the time.
Now that same girl is
still with the company,
her daughter is 14 years
old, but at the time this was
before the Flint water
crisis and the water was bad.
She lived in the area
where it was highly
contaminated when I met her.
So what if she was still standing there
with her daughter three,
four, five years later
and her daughter would have
been drinking that lead water?
Now her daughter got all-A
student, play softball,
and been through all
kinds of training from,
man, everything, from just,
everything kids could
possibly do in the suburbs.
This young girl has been
able to experience that life.
You know what I'm saying?
And by being raised by me
as her father, you know,
so my thing is to do a good thing.
You know, I've did from
Flint, with the drugs,
I did a lot of bad,
So as I seen the profitability and the,
in the real business aspect
of doing what I was doing
instead of me, you know, like
I said, I don't disrespect
nobody is in the game and how they do it,
cause I came from it.
But my heart is in a
totally different place
because I was able to find
out how to do it legitimately
in a way that can be profitable
for me and the girls
and don't, and children,
and it don't hurt nobody,
or bring nobody pain or no hurt.
And I've seen a lot of
pain and hurt in the game,
both of them, you know?
So my thing was to try
to move away from it.
So, I was like I said,
the game changed my life
for the better, period.
Made me a better person, made me,
Don Juan, the Bishop, whatever,
I call him the Chairman.
But he is one of my best friends for real.
He showed me how to be
a friend, how to be--
the man don't cuss. The man don't litter.
These are things I learned from him and
took those things into
my life to be like that.
Not just, not from him, having the girls,
what he did, the man is a genuine friend.
An honest person.
From all I've seen with my own eyes.
Now, when other people may
have other perspectives,
that's on them.
But this guy right here is something,
He, to me, he is who he say he is
and I never seen anything different.
And the things I've seen is things people
may not even know him for, but
those just two things alone
not cussing and not putting, you know,
not even littering, he don't
throw nothing out the window,
He don't drop no trash, no way.
He don't do none of that.
You know?
And he has more qualities.
So, you know, meeting the
people that I met in it once
and I got to give all
the players a shout out,
especially my Shy town
players, you know, all the P's
in the Shy, and my closest ones,
one thing they taught me
from coming from Flint
and being a hustler,
we was always in competition,
even though the players
at the player's ball,
all the players in the competition to win
and be the best player.
But one thing I learned
being with the players
and being with the Bishop is
that we compliment each other.
I never got as many compliments
from men as I did when I met the players.
"Hey, player man, nice
suit, nice shoes, man.
Nice, oh, man, you and your game
looking good, man, bam, bam.
They compliment you the whole time,
celebrating with you,
not downing you hating on you.
Not, you know, it's just
a different feeling around
about being around a
group of people like that,
you know, that's supportive, and that's
in the same sequence with
you, but on a positive level
because they, ain't jealous of you,
they ain't mad at you or nothing.
They may want what you got
but at the same time,
but even not having it,
they still know how to congratulate you.
And that's church. For real.
- [Interviewer] You want to,
maybe, take off your glasses?
- Alright, come on.
- [Interviewer] What do
you look for in a woman
when you're looking for
somebody to work for you?
- A flat stomach. (laughs)
A flat stomach, ladies,
if you ain't got your
stomach flat, you want to be
with the Black Heff?
You want to be a part of Team Concept?
A flat stomach is the essence
of your success. Period.
It's the difference
between, you can be ugly,
but with a flat stomach and a nice round,
you can buy booty and titties,
but you can't, you might
can get all that sucked out of there,
but just come with it ready,
That way it's going to
still look natural and good.
A flat stomach is very
important to be a member
of Team Concept Entertainment
Services, my company,
and to be with the Black Heff
and represent what I stand for.
- [Interviewer] Other than sex for money,
are the girls sometimes
getting into like, you know,
- I don't have anything,
I don't have sex for money going.
That's what I'm trying to tell you.
This is what I brought,
I provide a unique service.
The service I provide is life
skill and managerial services
for only exotic dancers
working in Team Concept,
meaning those in sequence together,
focused on the same and common goal.
And that common goal is success.
Yeah, but I don't,
there's no sex for money.
So let's put the X on that
one with the Black Heff.
I don't have girls that
have sex for money,
even since the pandemic has been bad.
And we're out here right now
in Los Angeles, California.
All the strip clubs have closed down.
Well in Texas, the strip
clubs were open back up
within eight to nine, eight to 10 weeks.
And girls have been
dancing the whole time,
and the whole state has been opened up.
So I've been blessed,
my business hasn't had to suffer,
but when the clubs were closed,
my I couldn't make money
because that's all I
got is girls that dance.
My company just only
manage exotic dancers.
So they're not leaving the club
and not doing this they're not doing that,
everything that happens,
happens inside of the club.
Nothing's outside of the club.
- [Interviewer] What is
the core of (indistinct)
your relationship? She looks
at you as a daddy figure or--
- No, I was see, it's not
a pimping, once again,
It's not, it's a manager
client situation is what I got.
Now when I pimped, of course,
yeah, my hoes called me daddy, you know,
but this is you talking
over 20 plus years ago.
You know, I don't even,
cause now, you know, as far
as the game go, when I took the name
the Black Heff, honestly, I took a lot
of pride in taking that name,
but I had to stand on it.
Like I stood on pimping when I pimped.
I did everything the right way,
I didn't break a rule in it.
I never would have.
Because I wanted to do it the
way it was supposed to go.
So when I became the Black Heff,
I had to stand on my game and what I did,
the way that Hugh Hefner
sorta stood on his.
And so I studied a lot of, you know,
studied a lot about him, did research.
And one thing he did, he always stayed
with what he believed in.
Back when he started in
the late sixties, seventies
whenever he started really
starting to have his little
after dark show, but the
"sexual orientation of women"
and exploitation of it was
really shunned, shunned,
you know, they looked bad upon that.
So he had the head of the CIA,
which was J. Edgar Hoover,
every Playboy magazine,
that came out, every single issue,
he had an FBI agent assigned to go
through every page of the magazine
and read every word and make
sure that there's nothing
that he did or said or
showed that will incriminate.
And this was every issue.
And this was a white man with a
with a white, you know, CIA
director, J. Edgar Hoover,
this is a white man.
So you see if they was doing that to him,
what would they do to the black
one that's calling hisself
you know, patterning himself after him?
What would I have to stand on?
So when I had that
information it let me knew
that I had to really be able
to take whatever came at me
once I did it and really putting
it out there for business
I had to be able to stand on something
that couldn't be shaken or, you know,
cracked or bent or folded,
because I was hiding behind something.
So everything I did, I did on
the upfront, I got contracts,
I did this, I got with CPAs,
I got with attorneys, talked
to people in different places.
I had people do research for me
that was in different
industries pertaining to that.
And I just found out the
best way to really do it.
And then I found out a way
that was going to help me,
the business, help the girls,
and let everybody live a
prosperous and winning life.
You know what I'm saying?
Beside a lot of times,
the lack of, you know,
the P might come up, but
the girl don't get nothing.
You know what I'm saying?
Or she get just something.
And then when she gone, it
ain't nothing else left.
The game ain't none for, to do.
What with this company,
the girls would come
and acquire the information
that they can make
in the club and dance.
And then after they term, they first term,
they can renew their term
and have a second term
but after their terms, they
can go and take the information
and run with it and make
the money on their own.
But they came somewhere
like went to college
to be able to learn how to do this
with structure, stability,
without drugs, without alcoholism,
all these things are monitored.
But being able to learn
how to really be a dancer
and not going there green,
searching and looking
around looking stupid
but going in there with experienced girls
and learn how to become
an experienced dancer
but make the big money.
Instead of going in there,
green wasting time drinking
doing pills, doing, somebody say
"take this" or "do this," or "do that,"
No, you go in there with people
that's already respected,
already know how it go,
and they can help you
avoid all the pitfalls
that any new dancer would
actually go in there
and come in contact with.
So it's a revolutionary system, man.
So as you, I see you as you
insinuate different things.
You know, I understand them clearly,
because I've truly have
did them all in the past,
but now, you know, it's been
so long since I've done that.
I've been, you know, even
before I was recognized
as the Black Heff, I was already living
the Black Heff lifestyle with these girls
and in houses and doing what
I had been doing before TMZ
or Discovery Channel, or,
I've been on Discovery Channel, TMZ,
on the Talk Soup with Ryan
Seacrest, and on Quest TV
because they license the
Discovery Channel episode over
and licensed that over to they TV,
so I've been on four
networks without anything
without them just seeing me
and throwing me on there, you know,
or being a part of something
that they threw on there.
But it was so interesting, they
couldn't deny it, you know?
You know, as I've represented it
and represented it to the fullest,
and loved it when I represented it.
But right now, what I
stand on, or what I do,
is a revolutionary thing that has evolved
from me knowing the pimping
to doing something totally different.
That's like I said,
it actually works for
the male and the female.
Both counterparts actually can win in it
because there's no,
it's a different kind of stand on it.
And you basically give
somebody the strength you had
instead of taking from whatever strengths
that they can give you.
You see what I'm saying?
My strength is passed on.
So people, women are standing
up, they're not afraid.
They talk, and they look at me in the eyes
in different ways,
because they have to look
these men in the eyes
at the club to do business.
So I don't teach them to look
down and not look at men.
You know, I teach them
how to look men in the eye
and talk to them, and learn
how to be assertive listeners,
and different things like that.
The company teaches.
But these are qualities you need
to be able to make money in
adult entertainment industry,
in strip clubs, particularly.
- [Interviewer] So when
you were, you were pimping
in what cities, Memphis?
- Well, I pimped in a lot of cities,
but I originally came
from Memphis when I was,
you know, was pimping cause
through the one thing
about the strip clubs,
you can still pimp
because you can have girls
cause it's every customer come in there,
want some pussy.
So with that being said, you can easily,
you know, girls can go in there
and make money dancing and doing dances.
But it's a guy that's just
in town for the night with a room
he want to take a pretty
girl to the room with him.
And he willing to pay 3, 500, 1000,
depending on what she asked for,
who she is, what she looked like.
So you get, so you make the money
in the strip club dancing,
and you might have you two,
three dates lined up after the club.
Every date, this first nut, you know,
the first hour, the first nut.
We know the nut come faster than an hour.
We can get some money.
- [Interviewer] Which of the
girls that you've worked with
has been your favorite?
- All the ones that made money,
them the ones I remember.
Them all my favorites.
The ones that made the money,
The ones that, you know,
it never was a favorite if
they didn't make the money
because a lot of the ones
that didn't make money
or just came through,
you know, pass through.
I really don't even remember
them that, you know?
- [Interviewer] Other than a flat stomach,
what personality traits
does a girl need to do this
this line of work?
- You just got to believe in herself.
That's what I mean.
It's everything is believing in yourself.
You can't, you know, you can, you know, or
have the ability to listen,
to learn to believe in yourself.
You know, everything, people, you know,
even girl hoes go out there.
They believe they can go out
there and get that money.
You know, the ones that's
really getting money.
They know it ain't no problem,
I'm going to go break these tricks.
I'm going to go get this money.
I'm going to go find daddy his money.
I ain't got no problem with that.
Matter of fact, let me go
ahead and get ready right now.
I'm on my wait.
Yeah. He going to be happy tonight.
You know, that's what real hoes do.
You know what I'm talking
about with this in the game?
See what I'm saying?
So I don't understand
it clearly, you know,
like I said, I've had some
real hoes that I really
they didn't come like that.
I really trained them.
But like I say, once again,
when I was coming from Flint
going to Memphis, I was more
on my drug dealer mentality.
I was more on my, you know,
real grimy hood nigga mentality.
You know what I'm saying?
And so I really didn't know
the position of a player
and a true PI, you know
what I'm talking about,
that was really supposed to carry yourself
in the likeness of a
gentleman at all time.
So once I got with the
game, then I learned that,
you know, I let a lot of
those traits and ways go,
but it took me a while,
I still had a lot of
my Flint that had been
on me all my life with
me when I got to Memphis.
So I really trained girls
a whole lot rougher,
and cause they was black.
It was a lot harder to fight
for them than white girls.
So I had to really train them
with a little bit more of a, you know,
a little bit thicker skin,
thicker coat, so to speak.
And so, but I was already had a thick
real thick coat on me.
So it wasn't nothing
to pass that one down.
But then when I learned, you know,
started dealing with, you know,
learn to turn it to
legitimate and started dealing
with white girls and learned
and watched how easier
they can make the money
without doing anything,
and how the clubs can just work for them,
they don't have to go do dates
outside of the club and do--
If I did that, I'd be the richest,
one of the richest guys alive.
So if I was still
pimping with white girls,
my money would be to
the ceiling right now.
Matter of fact, I just come in here
and just hide some in this big warehouse.
As long as you can keep a secret, (laughs)
you did, but because I'm not pimping,
and I try to get girls that's clean,
that's not on drugs,
that's not alcoholics,
and keep them steered in that same fashion
the whole time during their
doing their two year agreement,
then that's a job in itself
because there's so many
distractions in the strip club
from guys bringing drugs in,
alcohol floating all
day, to music playing.
It's a fricking party.
So how do you keep girls clean
from going to work at a
fricking party every single day?
Hmm, not, now.
Now you see what I'm saying.
Now you see, and then being black,
and calling yourself the Black Heff,
how much attention you're
going to draw to yourself?
So how clean do I have to
actually have this thing
to pull it off?
I got to have this shit squeaky clean.
It can't be a dump,
got to keep dusting and cleaning
and looking under, and vacuuming it, yeah.
because I have to stand on that.
- [Interviewer] And you've
stayed out of trouble.
- Of course, yeah.
Because I did the right thing.
You do the right thing,
the right things happen.
No, no, I ain't stupid.
I come from a righteous family.
Yeah. What is honesty, man?
Like I said, it's the thing about,
I feel good to be able to tell the truth,
so I don't mind talking,
I can talk this to a girl's mother
to a girl's father, even
though they may take it
in some type of way, but I feel I'm not,
I don't feel any type of way
to express the truthfulness
about my business and what I do.
Because if you ask me the same thing,
over you ask me that again,
the same question I'm
gonna have the same answer.
I don't have to lie.
You see what I'm saying?
It feels good to not have to.
I have nothing to hide
and to be able to put it
in people face either because
they're going to think
that it's something that shouldn't,
that that's going to be bad.
But when they speak to me,
and really see what I do,
and see what the services I provide,
and how I have changed people lives,
even if I don't bring a
girl into this industry
there's going to be a girl
going into a strip club
trying to make money somewhere.
Every single day.
Across this country, across this world.
So I don't control that,
but if I can take somebody
that would go in there
where they could go in there
and show them how to do it the right way,
how to make a better life for themselves,
how to treat it as a business,
instead of as just quote on quote,
"goin somewhere to make
a little money off me"
"and have some fun," you know,
and really be able to structure
and get their bank accounts together,
you know, give them structured living
and show them how to live
in a structured environment,
and comfortable eating the right foods,
drinking alkaline water,
I mean, there's all, there's
so many different things
that we do to keep ourselves
fresh, fresh, and youthful
and to become better and not worser.
You see girls in the game,
I've seen it plenty of
times, a lot of times.
The chick be with a guy, as you do,
As the years go on, you see her,
she look worser and worser.
If you see any girl that
you ever seen with me,
as the years go on, she
looks better and better.
She went from a young lady,
to a woman, to a grown woman,
to a business woman,
depending on the length
that she stayed with my company.
So these are the things that I do,
you know what I'm talking about?
And I'm proud to be
able to do those things.
And I'm not shameful in any type of way
because what I do is the right thing.
I'm not stealing, taking, lying, cheating.
Like I say, I'm honest.
People already know exactly what it is.
You know what I'm saying?
And now with the system,
instead of the world
I'm not the person managing the money.
The girl makes the money she manages.
She has access to make,
do all the things that comes
with being a business person.
So they know how to not just take care
of the money and run
themselves and manage it.
But they know they see the operations
of dealing with banks,
and making deposits,
and doing this with,
with legitimate money,
with the money that's not,
you ain't doing nothing wrong
and make the money just dancing.
So, I mean, it's a totally
well-crafted system
that, like I said, I put
together with not just me
and my thinking from past experience
but with some real, you
know, professional opinion
you know, put inside of it.
And like I say, we've yet
to even reach our peak, you know,
like I said, that was
just everything I've done
so far to me was just practice.
The real game is about
to start now. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Alright, Black Heff.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting.
- Pleasure's all mine.
- [Interviewer] Thank you, man.